well I am Christina Venegas and we will
I want to invite bus at least I got a TA
go the screenwriter and I doodle
Ripstein to join me up here please
[Applause]
I always have to take a deep breath for
this congratulations on this premiere
first of all it is a real pleasure for
me to be here with you again and it's
been a long time and this film is I
think she was writing this film when we
first met a long time ago and so it's
wonderful to finally see it in its full
and its full run so I I do want to start
by asking you about the story I know
that's a story that is taken from real
events and there is another film that is
made of this story so if we could begin
with the genesis of the project and how
you worked on it together because you
work together in a very particular way
and and I want to get to that - well
after O'Neill this story was written it
was written in a book about crimes it's
a real thing it's a real story that
happened in the United States in 1949
and he knew of the story here we liked
it and then in 1973 or something around
and Lerner Castle they did a film called
the honeymoon killers about the same
case so he Arturo forgot about it and
one day we were here in La Jolla walking
in the beach and there was a nurse with
very blond very with tons of makeup and
and all in an elderly guy and he told me
he reminds me a woman and even him in a
crime which is corral I think I changed
the names of course and and he told me
this story and I love this story and we
went to we went to the middle take added
to the erotic he's a witch sign English
Ameritech and I read like two meters of
material in those days in La Jolla and
and their tutor told me it's impossible
to do it in Mexico and and really it was
very hard to translate the story to
Mexico mainly because a family from the
familiar net nets and the neighbors nets
around people make this almost this
history almost impossible to happen in
Mexico no Widow can can go or fool
around in those days and so we get to
the conclusion that we could put that DC
story up north near to the border which
is much unpopulated and close it to the
States
actually it's like 50 kilometers away
from the border so it looks like Texas
exactly look like Texas and then the
other twist that was very difficult to
adapt that that was that in Mexico we
don't have that penalty and both killers
die in sin Singh in 49 so we found this
wonderful truly and very realistic way
of deal with people that you want to get
rid of which in Spanish has a term and
the term is lay fuga which not or not
other language in earth harvest we when
we have the translators they cannot find
the way to put lay fuga in all Latin
America and Spain we know exactly why
women and it was much more
cinematographic so that's more or less
the story the story also goes that I
read this when I was a young man and
like didn't I said to puzzle when we met
this fat woman in La Jolla I said that
she reminds me of Martha deck so they
told her the story and I said but we
can't
do this we film because it's sort of
recently there was this letter Castle
movie and but years later I said let's
try to do it I mean nobody will remember
this film nobody will even know it was
it was Maidan finally when it was shown
in Venice and won a bunch of prizes
there are things like that I remember
but the roots are coming to me and
saying this is the remake of the castle
film there and I said yeah that's my
favorite movie in the dragon and
everybody in Venice had seen this film
so everybody everybody it was
everybody's favorite movie at that
moment so I felt a bit down trodden for
those terms but well anyhow it's there
it survived it's 20 years old and as you
could see it was dedicated to land her
castle and to Martha Beck and raymond
fernandes the true true pillars and so
it's a little love story with madame
love mad love is a very peculiar term
that was sort of picked up by the
Surrealists in the in in in in in the
20s and it led them to do many of the
things they they they didn't conceived
and the the notion of mad love is is
quite fascinating because it's it's love
above and beyond any barrier and or or
or any moral or other issues so that was
the the reason we want to make it it's
it's humanity in its rawest essence and
one of the things that's really
interesting
- it's the way in which we're talking
about love here so we have the way in
which she loves the romantic story the
romantic novels there were the film
stars
so film stars play a big role in this
and she loves Charles Boyer and and and
eventually wants to turn him into John's
boy but it's but then there are also
gradations of jealousy different ways in
which you know he talks about her as
they heard her forms of jealousy and his
forms of jealousy so could you talk
about and and and she's such a well they
are fascinating characters but I mean
it's it's they are truly astonishing
people oh yeah and they fell in love
between each other because of their
demeanor their but Isis biases they fell
in love because they need each other
because they feel themselves there were
failures and so the failures the sense
of failures linked them together and
then if you start killing people you're
even link her together so there was no
way to for them but to love each other
because he know that I'm that I have
flaws and he loved me exactly for that
and there's no love story without Josie
my immediate first person I mean as I've
I haven't killed her but that's right
what can I say that so but the other the
other undertone in these room in these
you know incredible scenes between them
and where this relationship is is you
know being explored are these long takes
that you know really bring us into those
moments and and just keep us there and I
know I mean this is I've seen many many
of your films and so I know that this is
this relentless kind of way in which
we're brought into these lives can you
just talk a little bit about how you
work with well you know how you think
about shooting those sequences and using
the long takes I don't think about it I
certainly do very very very closely I
I've been doing movies for for 53 years
now so it's been a long career and no
fortunate career and I I started many
many years ago and I remember a little
scene in which I needed to see a
character and go the wither as she goes
through a sort of a maze in her house
and I wanted to follow her and there
were the equipment in in in 1965 that
the cameras and the stuff was very heavy
are very complicated to move so he had
this little Airy flex and that was stuck
to the operator said with bandages and
think so it wouldn't shake and and and
and one of those shares for invalids
with wheels and so that's how we did it
and I loved it at that time and I
remember work I was 21 years old when I
was shooting that movie and I had an old
old cameraman the oldest in the industry
in Mexico and I told him my I I wish I
had
camera that could fly I was had a camera
with wings many many many years later
the digital platform gave me that
equipment started to be smaller and and
easier to transport and and and it
helped me do the film's like I wanted to
I wanted my films to have an undulation
and not the sharpness of cutting I
wanted to capture everything in one
scene in one whole scene and I've been
doing that for many many years now
every every scene is only one take and
you have to work around whatever you
however you need it so I do think about
it very closely and with pass when we
work the the the screen plays well she
writes he sits down a nurse in her study
and writes them and and after at the
very beginning she used to give me pages
and I read their pages but now it's the
whole thing but after the thing is
written and I I usually like it because
if I don't like it then I go ahead and
do what I was planning a while ago and
kill and so but I like it and we discuss
exactly how it should be written in
order to be filmed in order to be shot
with as you said beautifully a
relentless camera because I learned
quickly in my career that the element
the fundamental element make a movie
with is the camera and I learned
immediately after that that the way you
tell the story is the story
so the camera helps me to do that and we
have to she has to write it in order
that that has that is possible so it's
complicated because
you have to go through a lot of
obstacles yeah actually that was my
follow-up question because it would seem
that way because of the timing because
of the of the dialogue and and where and
because the takes are so long and it
brings us so closely into especially
that scene that I'm going to bring up
the scene which I'm assuming was a scene
that was censored that which I've only
seen this film in its previous version
so maybe you can walk us through this is
the scene towards the end where we
finally get to the mother and the
daughter and when she becomes pregnant
Corral is brought back to do the
abortion and then I believe it's that
sequence of the abortion that's been not
been there so it's about five minutes
that were reinstated into the film is
the abortion and the killing of the door
before the the censor the censorship
began when she get to the way to the
bathroom take the clothes off the little
girl and take it don't worry the water
will be warm etcetera but you don't see
her put it in the in the bathtub and
keep him down and to me those two scenes
were very important because first in the
abortion I began to have a link between
the two women especially that's kind of
link that only happened with females
from the performance of course when in
an abortion oh and I need to begin to
humanize corral the fat lady I have to
humanize her and then for me was very
important that in the killing of the of
the girl we see the pain and we see the
translation the main de mental switch
from their children's today to the
little girl she's killing her her
children and that's what destroys her
and us why he calls the police so for me
was absolutely on the Spencer
but named the French producer gonna save
my name because I hate him Marine car
meets M Cadoo said that he don't kill
children seen in camera he don't have
his against abortion etc etc I mean she
said she's she's Maoist he is my his
mouth he his ultra left and he's against
abortion and he don't kill Jews in
camera so I hate him I have to say that
in the name out loud I'll say it again
Marie in car meets you over the sensor
so so this scene as you saying it really
brings the whole built the whole film
the whole story from the beginning with
the story of the kids which I you know
the and this is not completely a story
that's that's absent from Mexican films
I mean we've seen these harrowing
moments in melodramas where you know
mothers are tearing their hearts out and
it's you know one scene or another
similar or not you know in this vein
where women are having to give away
their children or willingly give away or
killing their children so it's it's a
very difficult moment but in the story
you don't see that Mexican melodrama I
do it yeah no I know no in this film
this these two scenes were very
important for one reason this film has
the notion of duplicity
everything happens twice mirrors are
there to do a double image of things the
two-faced characters and everything
happens you see it it it it's it's very
symmetrical
and and I think structure is is
important in these cases so taking away
a bit of the structure sort of not
tumbles but makes the whole notion of
the structure of the film have have a
couple of flaws and was helped in this
case precise is he fall in love with her
because he was capable to give the
children away he decided to call the
police because she killed the child the
two turning points of the story are they
giving away this the destruction of the
children to me maternity is very
important I have to tell out loud I'm a
mother of three I was a mother since I
was very young in a really horrific
woman to me his maturity is very
important so in this history have to
emphasize she was a mother and that's
changed you forever
and in court and he now Rosco who plays
good I'll could you say a little bit of
because I think it's the key I mean a
cast is brilliant and and absolutely key
she made this movie she had made one
film maybe in very small roles she's not
an actress really she was he's an opera
singer and and and we cast her because
it's very complicated to find an actress
that's fat but sexualized that has these
two characteristics that are very
important for for this for this karate
and and when when I when I met her it
was frankly a surprise because he's got
very strange body she's like thinned on
top and fat but below so it was a very
peculiar to work with her in
in those in that sense where her 1/4
size the the size by sitting her giving
her back to the camera and almost
covering the whole the whole frame and
was it was very complicated to work with
her because she was not an actress all
the rest of the cast I mean the near
human is catches what are the brightest
actors in Mexico of course many separate
is included to Rolla who Anita North on
you know and the young girl Veronica
merchant the last victim they're they're
really bright actors and she was not so
she was very very nervous and very
scared it was when you're nervous was
scared it's not easy to work in a set
actors are very frail people you have to
treat them very very carefully even
though it's completely different than
from working with actors here it's it's
totally different didn't hear they have
the power they they they're they they
they have just the vocation did her
being nervous in any way helped her
performance because she's such a I mean
because she is so awkward in some scenes
and desperate and and she moves around
following him around and following
everyone so it's she's she's kind of a
nervous yes yes she's like the force of
nature in real life she's like a
hurricane and so when she's in camera
she has this kind of clumsiness Plus
history hit she tends to become
hysterics
but she's an opera singer she sediba a
real diva but it's fantastic to the
camera because she was able to portray
the and the subtle little moments very
well when she was jealous of the two
widows I adore her I was watching fair
thing she's like you switch feels like a
chocolate
so in the original story that you had
read in the in the book and that was
obviously the original story she was a
fat character right very peculiar
because she was very fat Martha Beck and
when they put him into prison and they
brought him from I remember where some
where Midwest to New York and it was a
very scandalous fadeev at an event in
the in the newspapers it was very very
well-known it was almost oj but in in in
those years which was different but in
in jail he raymond fernandes
was bald and had a scar and he thought
of themselves as a freak received
hundreds of letters from women in here
in the States
saying that they would marry him and and
she received a terrible hate mail and
there was one comment that she said to
one of the jailers when a woman jailer
is where she was kept she said
they they they hate me
not because I killed a child but because
in fact and and that was a sort of what
gave us also a notion of how we should
treat this this character and the the
other aspect that I found really
interesting is the way in which his
Spanish nough scums up and and also
there's the scene where I think it's the
first victim where they meet at the bar
and she says oh no no I don't want I
think it's her that she says I don't
want the Spaniards because they are son
profesor can can you just discuss a
little bit about that aspect of it
that's because she actually remo
fernandes a the expert killer was his
pioneers
and back then in those days those were
the days where there were Latin lovers I
mean romantic Doge and keep it in the
film means that in Mexico Spanier is a
European fancier and so it was useful
for the film they will were the days of
the Spanish exile after the war and what
the exam that we have we got in Mexico
which was very fortunate for Mexico were
the scholars intellectuals and very
important people which of course were
Republicans and that those days or
communists and thing things like that
that were seen not with good eyes with a
certain sector of society and Marie
supper is as the Catholic the
ultra-religious victim
she's there's a scene in here which is
absolutely wonderful where after they've
gotten married and she comes back into
his room and she really wants to be with
him and you know her body movements up
until that time you know the way that
she's holding herself very kind of
calmly and then suddenly she straddles
him in the bed and and it's just a
magnificent moment of the potential of
who she can play of Maresa so could you
just talk a little bit about working
with her money she was very difficult
because she's very good so she knows
about scene and how actors have to
things their basic and it's their bodies
and their voices that's the the
instrument so that that's hidden Marisa
handles it with with absolute beauty so
she knows exactly how to go about it
and and she was she was very precise
i-i-i have a choreography of every scene
exactly what's going out in those days
when we had photographic material we had
a few rehearsals and then we shot we
shot for nada no not not not many takes
because we had just a few cans of film
to to work with so it was choreograph to
position and Maresa in the choreography
and in the position was always exact
she's a really admirable actress and
difficult but I thank her for that it it
was really good and we're still friends
and that's you have said that somehow in
each film there's something that you had
that you left behind that you didn't do
that you wish you had done is there
something like that about this film yes
of course I wanted this film to be the
seven Samy arrive but it came out to be
this I tried my best but then again when
is what one is and I apologized now well
you put it back to the way it should
have been I suppose that's one of the
answers and difficult question it's like
do you have the same child where you
replace that child with the other one
who were who could be born four months
after it's impossible this is your
creature it's like your child you love
them whatever they are no short fat
stupid he's magnificent
this is my childhood is Magne it's
magnificent it's short and fun so how
did the two of you meet and start
working together
no we we met working there's a few
there's different versions we met
working and and bus used to write
stories in the literature and she
studied literature in school and and she
wrote comic books cultural comic comic
books there were dad app tations of 19th
century Mexican literature into comic
books and she wrote the adaptations for
that and we met that way and she was
doing television at the time and I met
her and I read a couple of things he we
talked first and she was very precise
saying things and I read a couple of her
things or very schematic things but she
talked to me she talked a lot it was it
was formidable then and she she's never
stopped and that's 32 years already and
no cake so she she was very fascinating
she was very precise and so we became
friends and one day I asked to do a one
rule for film one of the great writers
of Mexico and went to the the
authorities and they said yes we can do
this because it was a remake of a film
already already done and I called her on
the phone I said I want you to adapt
this book for me a movie what movie said
I said this one rule for little novel
called
Elega de Oro and and it was on the phone
and said no and hung hung the phone and
I called her and I said why no because I
don't do those things and I said hey
nice voice I started
you you you have to do it it's nice and
it's gonna be wonderful than you I've
never done this well you can do it this
way so I said no burn and so I called
her again and I said listen I give you
two hours to decide think about it
she knew the story well and I said I'll
give you two hours and so she said fine
give me two hours and and no cell phones
thing and so I called her ten minutes
later I'm impatient and so I said okay
have you thought about it they said well
okay yes and that's how we met
professionally and she wrote a
screenplay you know screenplays are
usually I don't know ninety a hundred
hundred and ten pages long no more than
that she the first version she gave me
was a screenplay it's a 90 page novel
and the screenplay had three hundred and
sixty five pages to read so I said it's
lovely but we can't do this we you have
to do it it was a normal movie at the
time it's a 40 year old movie or
something like that now and sort of said
I don't I only have an hour and 45
minutes to do this so we took away
things but what she what what she gave
me to read was absolutely wonderful pass
write writes her screenplays opposite to
everything you've read on the books of
how you should write a screenplay she's
the complete no no of screenplays she
describes everything she describes the
odor of spaces she describes what
characters are feeling of the things
that you can't shoot but that help the
whole crew to know that we're doing the
same movie there's no interpretation of
I thought the movie meant this sees as
an actor or I thought the film looked
like that says the camera man and
no but the the way she describes it and
just the the the whole work is in
equivocal everybody knows exactly that
they're doing one film and not
interpretations of many films and that
one film is my film
they've always said in in these
territories film is a collaborative art
in Mexico I know it's a collaborative
air art but they have to collaborate
with me that's the way to do it and and
there it's different we have different
ways of working the pyramid in Mexico
than here but working with pasta scripts
has been one of the one of my great good
moments and advantages she need witness
is definitely one of the most beautiful
and productive partnerships for sure and
I think we're almost out of time but I
just want to say that it is a privilege
having you here and for us to be able to
see the film and it's in this form and
to be able to appreciate the full the
fullness of these characters brutal as
they are because it is a brutal reality
we're talking about but but that is part
of what makes your films extraordinary
before we leave naturally I wanna I want
to thank the Academy who were gracious
enough to invite us to show our work
here it's of course a privilege for us
the people that have we're we're kind
enough to invite us or have been very
gentle and so far I never I don't know
if they had seen the film yet but they
it's been very nice being here and
naturally I want to thank you all for
coming
here to see us because it is you that
makes us the invisible filmmakers
visible even if it's just for the
duration
so in our name thank you
you